iconic sand dollar lounge has been
transformed into a winter wonderland
pop-up bar jc fernandez is live with the
details on how you can toast
to the season hey jc
hey rocky and kendall how about a
christmas cocktail right here this is
the
santa santa rex santa rex this is
awesome it's a
it's a miracle on spring mountain and
this is nathan with the sand dollar
lounge
so what inspired you guys to create this
christmas wonderland
well i mean firstly it was it started
off on the east coast um and it had a
lot to do with philanthropy and giving
back to the communities um there's only
one in every city so we are the only
miracle bar
um in las vegas which is great but we
just want to bring people together for
the holidays
i love it because outside the bar it
feels like a wednesday you walk in here
it feels like christmas day
talk me through the cocktails we have
here on the table also some of the
cocktails are all very festively driven
um the santa rex the yipikaya mother
we have a jingle bells nog that's really
good so we kind of have a variety that
has the base spirits um that kind of
covers the whole spectrum
i love the yippie caye because die hard
is a christmas movie right die hard's a
christmas movie let's walk over here
let's get a shot of these these are
gorgeous is it is this a christmas tree
competition or just some beautiful trees
no just beautiful trees i mean
you know we got a big wall here and a
lot of space to cover we wanted to make
sure that
that everything had a little bit of
christmas essence to it i tell you every
corner of the bar
is is it is a selfie what are the
christmas beers that you guys oh
i mean it's a variety but i mean
everything a lot of eclectic beers um
from brewers like prairie so you've got
some high-end beers that are really cool
and then you know some of
some of those are a little bit more
mainstream let's walk over this way
because tonight uh here at the miracle
on spring mountain the sand dollar
lounge you guys are doing something very
special there's a charity italian
we've got a pop-up pizza kitchen where
james tree he's from esther's kitchen
is going to be cooking pizza inside here
what's the charity time
so uh it starts about seven o'clock um
and james trees
you know owner of esther's kitchen you
know a good friend of ours we're
bringing in all these local celebrity
chefs
um and it's an opportunity to give back
so the 15 that you spend on the pizza is
going to go directly
to the las vegas rescue mission i love
it because you can come in here you can
it's dine in or take out grab your pizza
and go and you get the money right away
and you insert it right here and there
is your donation
to a great charity coming up in the four
o'clock hour you guys are doing
something very special for hanukkah
we'll talk about that coming up in the
four o'clock hour we'll send back to you
guys in the studio
i'm gonna drink myself a cocktail jc
does these ones on purpose he gets to
hang out at pop-up bars yeah i think you
noticed that
yeah i'm starting to like see a trend
myself yeah yeah we're gonna have to
talk to him about that
please listen you hear us jc i'm a
little jealous over here